I'm taking MCP, which is modified citrus pectin powder, you suggested with the green
drink.
I happen to have a couple of models of MCP capsules by pectosol that I ordered before
I started a cutters clinic would that be okay to take them to help with inflammation
and panic.
Yes, so pectosol is modified citrus pectin and it has a lot of beneficial effects on your
body with collected three, I have a whole multiple videos just on that.
But it is also a key later.
So modified citrus pectin falls into my category of mild to moderate key later.
So it's actually really beneficial to help grab stuff and pull stuff out of your body.
There's just literally no downside to modified citrus pectin.
So you could take that outside of your green drinks at a different time, yes.